people from Left Right and middle like
you and that's not an easy thing to do
no when your messaging is hard work
Dirty Jobs don't chase Your Passion some
of the stuff that you say could piss off
the other side but they still like you
how do how are you so likable where
people want to hear from you even though
they disagree with you that's an
extraordinarily nice way to frame a
really thoughtful question thank you I
don't I don't really know except to say
that part of it
has to do with Optics and you know I
freelanced in this crazy business for
for 20 years before Dirty Jobs became a
thing and when it became a thing the
Optics of that show at least in the
first season
it was just feces from every species
right I mean most people in the country
got to know me as a guy crawling through
a sewer and so they saw me literally
covered in other people's crap with
condoms stuck to my rubber suit as I
attempted to do whatever the god-awful
job was and so I think part of it was
well whatever this guy has to say
whatever it is he's selling whatever it
is he wants me to think or believe or do
he's covered with other people's crap so
how how how full of crap can he can he
really be you know what I mean it's like
there was so much baked in humility for
that show and and I'm not saying it's
because I'm a humble guy I I'm not
frankly in fact for 20 years I I was
impersonating a host and pretty good at
it you know uh and in in my world you
get paid based on your ability to create
the illusion of competence and uh and
and knowledge in in in short bursts
that's what hosts do Dirty Jobs simply
required me to stop doing that take the
pie in the face let the person I was
with be the expert and assume the role
not of a host or as or an expert but as
a
as an avatar as a as an apprentice
frankly so that's the long answer to
your question I think people got to know
me as a guy who came out of the gate
saying I don't know could be wrong
probably am but here's what I think
and so I got a certain amount of
permission as a result of that show to
to weigh in on things that frankly I'm
really not that qualified to talk how do
you view people you disagree with you
know for yourself like if you uh what is
this you just I found this on to your
point Pat we're such an at a divided
time in America today right I mean
possibly and and definitely In Our
Lifetime
um and we talk about being a unifier
versus being a divider sure
um and we had this conversation
yesterday and we were like well is he
more right is he more left and we we Pat
looked into who's following you and it
was people all across the the aisle not
even politically just across the media
Spectrum across everything Ellen and
then Mike Huckabee and yeah you know all
wide range and here I just looked at
this article micro hits number one on
top TV personality surgery like meaning
somehow you're a very beloved figure
you're not a divisive figure and uh well
I mean it's I'm just looking at the
stats your brother I mean this ain't my
opinion hey man it's on the Internet
it's got to be true but look at that
hair by the way holy cow yeah this is
amazing well Mike Mike let me let me ask
this here's a question I wanted to ask
and I know you this is a uh uh really
hard to get something like this to
happen but we're living in a time where
the last two and a half years uh if you
want to talk about divide and conquer
you know split the country you know
magic crowd hates the other side the
other side hates Mega crowd look at
these Republicans these Democrats prove
acts anti-vaxx it's so much about you
know I was on a flight the other day guy
sitting next to me on the flight back
from DC the entire time he had his uh he
had his mask on in your mind you already
can say this person voted for you know
what kind of Channel he watches you can
probably list 20 things this guy does
and then you know it's unfortunate but
we kind of are doing that so for for you
whether it's I know you're an Iran guy I
know you you're a big reader you quote
philosophers your guy that was you know
big on
self-development was the concept of How
to Win Friends and Influence People a
natural thing that you grew up with or
was it something your mom taught you
your dad taught you a book you read how
did that personality come about to learn
how to get along with people you
disagree with
um I it was probably a little bit of all
of it but your example is so insanely
relatable I mean I I sat next to a guy
coming out here with two masks on right
and when I sat down he offered me a mask
and I said hey thank you but I'm going
to go ahead and uh and he had already
warmed it up I mean he pulled it out of
his pockets
not what he was wearing no okay that and
so naturally I I offered him my
underpants
no I I I just said thank you
um but I'm gonna you know I'm good he
said okay and um and I sat there and I
thought what do I say to him next I mean
we're gonna spend six hours together and
I it's not like we have to have a
conversation but to your point I didn't
see a mask I saw a Talisman I saw an
indicator of some other set of beliefs
so I stepped back from that and I said
well wait a minute it is is it just a
mask is it something else and then I
thought well what if
what if he doesn't feel well what if he
thinks he might be running a low-grade
fever what if he's actually not scared
but trying to be as considerate as he
possibly can to the people in this
pressurized aluminum tube that are about
to defy the laws of gravity and what if
he's just offering me a mask though may
I might offer somebody a breath mint if
I had an extra one you know what I mean
now do I believe that's where he was
coming from actually no I don't I think
I think he was probably coming from
where you think he was coming from
um but I felt better
thinking that I was sitting next to a
guy who was concerned about me Optics
and then I just went on with my life
yeah you know so look you can assign any
meaning to anything whether it's a mask
or the release I just looked at for the
first time that I wasn't able to
immediately sign because I wasn't sure
what I was doing right and so in those
moments where you're not quite sure
what's happening you either just stick
your head in the sand and go la la and
sign it and hope for the best uh or you
put yourself in the other person's place
and say well why would they why would
they ask me to sign this maybe they're
worried that I'm going to [ __ ] them up
somewhere down the line by by
withholding a permission or something
right and so it's all that if you're if
you're able
and willing and interested to look at
the man behind the mask and ask yourself
a slightly different question then study
after study shows you might not be an
[ __ ] that's a that's a very good
system to consider so the next time I'm
going to sit next to a person with a
mask I'm going to be asking myself and
processing it that way toward your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
[Music]